months leading up to 9 11 the cia
sounded the alarm that something was
coming a new cbs news documentary that
airs tonight takes us inside the cia's
hunt for al qaeda and its then leader
osama bin laden this is a preview
[Music]
from
april to
mid-july of 2001
there was a significant increase
in intelligence reporting about al-qaeda
planning attacks
catastrophic attacks
multiple simultaneous attacks
history changing attacks
we'd seen chatter before other
operations
but they started using language we had
never heard before they were calling it
olympic sized
armageddon
there were real plots being manifested
the world felt like it was on the edge
of eruption
it's early this tuesday morning the 11th
of september 2001
[Music]
from the heart of new york city the
first job of any government is to
protect the country and protect its
people
but you don't get credit for what you
stopped
if you don't stop them all
[Music]
and we were unable to stop the big one
[Music]
for us
there was a personal dimension
3 000 americans have been killed
the city i grew up in had been blown up
there was an emotional piece of this
because we had woken up every day of our
lives
trying to stop what just had happened
it's still so emotional we're joined now
by former acting and deputy cia director
michael morell whom you saw in that clip
20 years ago he served as the cia's
presidential daily briefer and was with
president george w bush on 9 11. he is
now cbs news senior national security
contributor and joins us at the table
mike it's good to see you great to see
you you know i'd forgotten that you were
with the president that day and you were
there at that school because we didn't
even know what we were looking at but
here's a question you're the perfect
person to be here today because your
knowledge is so vast the question is do
you do you think we're safer today than
we were back then
we are absolutely safer today than we
were back then gail
for two reasons one is
immediately after 9 11 we increased our
defenses so it is much more difficult
for terrorists to get into the united
states it's much more difficult for them
to move money is much more difficult for
anybody to hijack an aircraft
the second thing we did is we took the
fight to them overseas
so wherever we could find them whether
they were in afghanistan whether they
were in pakistan whether they were in
yemen we took the fight to them and
degraded them so that they didn't have
the capability anymore to attack us so
and we've done that consistently since 9
11. but now the taliban's in control in
afghanistan that's why i asked the
question do you think we're safer
because for a lot of people it seems
like we're right back where we started
right do you think that it's possible
that al qaeda could re-emerge
yes and whether that happens depends
entirely on us
so i told president bush on 9 11 that i
was
highly confident that what just happened
was the result of bin laden
and al qaeda i'm here to tell you today
that i am highly confident that the
taliban will allow al-qaeda to have safe
haven in afghanistan and al-qaeda will
want to reconstitute so the question is
will we allow that will we have the
intelligence capabilities to watch them
to see what they're doing
look at their plans and intentions look
at their capabilities and then will we
have the military capability to go in
there and degrade them
if we need to and will we have the will
to do that
if we do that
they won't be a threat if we don't they
could be a threat within 12 months do
you consider al qaeda and the situation
in afghanistan to be the single biggest
threat facing america today so not right
now right i worry about al-shabab and
somalia i worry about isis in north
africa i worry about domestic terrorism
here
but if we don't do what we need to do in
afghanistan it will become the single
biggest threat again what will be the
legacy of our war in afghanistan
so i think about it as what's the legacy
of the entire war on terror right and i
think there's two pieces to it one is we
have protected the homeland since 9 11.
there hasn't been another 911. we all we
all worked very hard to make sure that
that didn't happen that's fantastic
that's success right we won that war
but at the same time
i think we've weakened america a little
bit because for those 20 years that we
were fighting a counter-terrorism war
and a counter-insurgency war the
russians and the chinese were catching
up to us conventionally and some of the
things we did post-911 the war in iraq
for example
caused political
division here at home right that we're
still paying for right all right michael
morell you have the last word on that
thank you very much for joining us today
race against time the cia and 911 a
production of our very own see it now
studios airs tonight at 8 7 central
right here on cbs and it's available
tomorrow on the viacom cbs streaming
service paramount plus